it's not messy Natalie hi Natalie
this is my living room first of all it's
good to see you yeah via the internet
via the zoom how are you doing with all
of this and what do you kind of make of
everything that's happening right now I
don't know I mean it's all it's all so
so crazy obviously I feel like everyone
has the same exact reaction to it um it
sucks but I feel like I feel like it's
like at least me personally like I think
I really needed like a break from
everything I know you really slow down
it feels like if the best thing to
compare it to is it feels like summer
break as a kid or like you have all this
time off and you're literally just
there's nothing to do exactly it was
like who are you quarantined with
Natalie so Natalie's my system and then
Taylor my other step she comes by and
then and then Ilya Ilya just moved here
like a week or two ago he's my friend
from my hometown and he's coming out
here to help us at work so he's here
full-time now and then inside I I put a
little gift for you it's a check for
$10,000
[Music]
I do want to talk about your newest
video oMG you gave away Xboxes you gave
away cash and you get it away freaking
cars right how does this all sort of
happen so in a lot of my videos we give
back to a lot of people
so there's quarantine and burns pandemic
there was a lot more people reaching out
the normal about like things they need
it like whether I was hot with mortgages
they just needed some cheering up or
something like that so yes I reached out
to this company I work with a lot a and
they said that they would love to do
something we use this thing called the
community app we had people text us
there and we got a couple hundred
thousand people to text us and that way
we could a hundred thousand people
texted you how many people Matt 250 yeah
two or 50,000 people which was a lot we
rented an RV and we went through like
all of LA and like you know part
different parts of California and we
would look at every city that we were
stopping by and we were seeing who
needed what so whether someone needed
like some cheering up we'd get them like
an iPad or like an Xbox or someone II
didn't I like to help with the mortgage
we'd give him like a check for $10,000
and then we gave a little over nineteen
people a check it was cool yeah there's
a lot of fun what was the most emotional
reaction that you got there's a couple
people it was the most interesting part
was like hearing what people were going
through and how much the money was gonna
help them like there was there was a
girl who's like dad's dad's car broke
down that he likes sells food out of
like he's like a street vendor type of
thing and he helped fixing that like
that was really gonna help with that and
then these are the people that like
we're planning on going like on this
huge road trip they they lost their jobs
and now that you know they're having a
tough time even being able to stay where
they're at we're people writing you from
outside of California and you just
couldn't obviously get huh yeah but the
best part is is the people that wrote
from outside of California I have their
numbers now or once I'm allowed to
travel or something we do a lot of
traveling within the states like I do a
lot of college shows where I do like q
and A's now I'll be able to access those
people did you read all 250
thousands yeah yeah I was reading for a
couple nights I believe last ten years
no Natalie Natalie was the one that was
going through all of them so I think I
was tough time reading so it was nice
that she stepped in in the meantime I
have I have been hooking up with Natalie
so yes I do have to ask you though
because at the very beginning of that
video you did make a joke about Natalie
yeah you said you guys are hooking up
now she wishes we get a Natalie reaction
yeah now what do you what do you say she
said absolutely not okay so no truth to
that you were just trying to like toy
with everyone's hearts I was even
thought it should be obvious at this
point there's never gonna be a time and
I'm not a broke up even if this pandemic
lasted 25 years and we were stuck inside
it's never going to happen
I did hear that the new roommate
how do I save a million oh yeah yeah he
had a crush on Natalie growing up is
that right I think he had yeah he um you
like confessed his love to her a couple
months ago I think everybody around me
really really likes Natalie and they all
have crushes on Natalie it's a real
bizarre thing maybe I know her too well
yeah it's crazy
well I was gonna say how are they
adjusting to being roommates that is
their love connection no I think for
Elliot's gone out the window cuz he's
coming to help us with work and one
thing that's more important and than
anything is a business so I think he has
put all his feelings to to the side just
yeah improve his work life well how do
you feel about people constantly
shipping you with Natalie or other
people I don't know I don't I don't I
don't really care I don't know
it should I have a reaction where I'm
like upset I mean it's like then the
Internet such an like it's an obvious
place like you make one video with one
it's always been like this from
beginning of time like you interact with
one female or somebody that people think
that like you look you with and then
everyone you know
or assumes you're dating or they want
you today like that's just how this is
how it all works
yeah well sir you feed into that a
little bit because you posted an
Entertainment Tonight video on your
chick top where we wondered if you were
baby yeah that was great
I found that video and I was like are
they dating and then the next thing I
know it's like a video and then your
chick talking about it like you know
small circle for me right now funny it's
like it's like I don't know what the
video was but they're sparking dating
rumors because we made a tick-tock
together and I was like hell yeah Wow
one tick tocking them I'm already in our
relationship
yeah but you did post another recent
video like questioning if you and
Madison we're dating so would you so
you're not dating no I'm not I'm betting
that there is no I'm not okay
in general are just not Madison I can't
choose between Natalie and Madison
that's too bad okay that's then that
brings me if you're not dating either of
them you did post in bumble video which
I'm assuming is another partnership that
you do are are you actually on dating
apps is the thing that you would do to
find love
I used to I actually moved out here I
was on Bombo like more than the average
person I feel like like when I was 18
like that's like like when I moved out
to LA and we didn't know anybody like
that's only my friends were always on
gumball I feel like well we were on a
lot more than now but because we don't
have as much time but I'm telling you
like the first year it was just like
bumbles are must use that did you go on
a lot of dates honestly maybe maybe one
or two it was just like another way of
talking to people wasn't even really
about meeting up with anybody it was
just like an entertaining to swipe
through pictures that's all I was any
good opening lines that you want to
share like any of that made you laugh
waiter you're hired I like to have my
opening picture on a dating app to be
with a dog because I find it that's such
an easy like easy thing for especially
Obama the girl has to say something
first right easy for a girl to open up
with a line about the dog or about your
puppy but never be like yeah yeah I
accomplished the polar bear way or one
of those yeah or even like a hi what's
up right all right well you are quite
the social star because you also just
won your second Kids Choice Award Thanks
yeah that's what was it like to win a
Kids Choice Award from your house that
was crazy I really really wish I could
be there because the kiss chores are
literally like my Oscars like they're
like the biggest I think I watched him
more than the Oscars again that's such a
big deal to me and I don't know I don't
know I I haven't been excited when I got
the call that I won one I was actually I
haven't been genuinely excited about
anything in like a long time as much as
I realized about that Kids Choice Award
when are you gonna get your own
Nickelodeon show I mean you want me to
good on it I'm not a good actor so I
don't think yeah well yeah no I don't
think I'd be especially on Nickelodeon
like it's a little - a little too PG for
me like for I don't know or for how I
would love to see more of you on my TV
and other celebrities would also like to
see you on TV because you hang out with
Kevin Hart obviously you and John Stamos
our BFF at this point J Lo is I know you
told JLo how's David Oberst you guys
what are you who it's not even a name
who is that I haven't see jaylen oh wow
Kevin Hart I only hire on with like
truth attacks but I love I love Kevin
Hart yeah I talk with him and as I was
going over to his house to take a
picture and I was I was like a storm
detector I was like what tick tock can I
make with Kevin Hart and like when I
came across that it was like wow this
looks like it was made for him these
celebrities reach out to you or do you
reach out to them
do they want help like raising their
social profile how does it like a year
ago or a year and a half ago it was
really tough like getting to like work
with a celebrity like it was like it was
always through somebody's kids like I
would reach out it so every today
I don't know youtuber I don't know like
you know but now now I feel like tick
tock has made digital like media so
mainstream that like yeah there are
there are more celebrities now reaching
out where they're just like I want to
build my social media presence and
that's that's like the best like they're
finally like you know traditional
digital are finally meeting out like a
certain point pretty exciting what
celebrity has surprised you that reached
out where you were like wow this person
wants to make something with me recently
literally two days ago I got a DM from
one of my favorites as a kid um you know
bam margera and he and he just he
messaged me that he really likes my
videos and that was crazy because I feel
like if there wasn't for like his his
shows I wouldn't give a you know I take
a lot of inspiration from what he did
and now is that was a really cool thing
yeah anybody anybody like the Josh Pat
cause like one of the first people I
ever worked with so I thought that was
crazy well is the bromance between you
and John Stamos still alive
a oh really hot boyfriend check oh my
god yeah I'm supposed to get on a call
with him later today yeah it's
definitely alive I I love those I love
like like like Josh Peck how many men
down John Stamos are some of my favorite
people they're like the best people to
go to to get advice from and like
they've been doing this for so long and
it's like I can literally ask him
anything they're literally like my
parents at this point so it's like a
really cool thing to have those people
around what is what kind of advice did
John say months give you what all he
says is that I need a haircut that's
that's that's the biggest advice I get
from John and he always every time he
comes by or I see him he's like I can't
like I'm so pissed I forgot my sister's
as he was to personally cut my hair
which I don't know why that's like I
think it is but I don't I won't let him
do it as beautiful as he is I don't
trust him before
are you letting the hair grow out during
horn Jean right now I think I have no
choice
yeah yeah you're not gonna have Natalie
cut it I just showered what are you and
John Stamos gonna talk about today are
you guys gonna film something no but we
have a call about something you know I
can't say it because it's I I hate this
and it's like it's like so many like
everybody works on so many things here
like yeah you know that's that's all la
is it's like you have like you have like
ten different projects going at once
like that's how it works and like 90% of
them don't see the light of day if I can
like say all the things that have fallen
through and that people don't know about
I'd be here all day so I just keep my
mouth shut is there one that really
broke your heart that never came to
fruition that broke my heart I think the
most was I had I had a like a Netflix
show I was I was pitching to Netflix
when I was getting like a million two
million views on my videos is basically
all my friends compete living in a frat
house on campus but not going to school
so it was because we never had the
college experience and it was like it
was like a it was like a reality show so
it'd be like old school meets like the
movie accepted five and it was like that
mixed with a little bit of Jackass so I
was like more reality-based kind of like
my videos would be and and yeah we
perceptive Netflix anything get it
didn't get picked up but didn't
everything happens for a reason is a
reality show something that you're still
interested in doing reality shows is
it's like a pretty heavy word for it
it'd be more when I say reality show I
mean like like it'd be more of like a
late-night style so it's like real but
it's not like there's no like drama or
like you know people arguing your PS
like that it's just be like more like
real life like sketches or bits or you
know like when Kimmel is out on the
street like or like Fallon is you know
doing a sketch with somebody I know did
you did you read the article where you
were dubbed the Jimmy Fallon of Gen Z's
I didn't read that article yeah yeah
that's bananas I don't think there ever
will be a Jimmy fan of any generation I
think everybody is like it's like
especially with like like I always try
to compare my videos to like something
but you can't because everything is so
differently television shows are
different YouTube videos are different
tick packs are different like it's so
hard to make compare comparisons with
traditional and digital media cuz it's
just such a different age look I don't
like I don't know what I am you know
what I mean like sometimes I like to
like like I'd be like okay if I could
compare myself to something i watch
growing up can I even do that and like I
don't know because I don't know where
I'm gonna be in five to ten years that
is that is a serious compliment that I
really my being late so that that is
that's a serious problem
I can see you with your own late night
yeah you have to say that because you're
interviewing me right no I'm dead
serious I would totally watch that I
feel like come on you know people would
watch that hopefully whatever happens is
that um in talks right now
maybe yeah John Stamos okay I don't know
if it's in talks it's it's definitely
one of those things that that we have
conversations about hundred percent but
it is hundred percent also one of those
things that is that okay this company
we're gonna try to do with them and then
it falls through or we're gonna try to
do here if foster or like I don't have
time and stuff like that it's definitely
one of those la things that I mentioned
yeah you also mentioned celebrity kids
loving you so I'm curious what celebrity
kids are big fans of yours and had their
parents reach out to well I think the
best example like a somebody's kid
reaching out that I did something with
was Courtney Cox's daughter that's how I
got to connect with Courtney Cox which
was really excited because my one of my
friends was the biggest friend's fan
I've always wanted to surprise or was
somebody from the show and and yeah and
then I think one of my friends met
Courtney's daughter like out on the
street and she was like I'd love it if
you did something my mom
and then he told me and I was like yes
yes yeah that's that's the best because
celebrities are you know they're
celebrities parents always want to do
whatever it takes to make their kids
happy is she everything that I think she
would be is she the frickin coolest yeah
a hundred percent oh my god
and and I should also add to this the
her her house is the most beautiful
house I've ever seen the most stunning
thing it's like right on the beach
there's like a tennis court a beautiful
pool I was in complete awe like it was
the most inspiring thing tomorrow laughs
like wow so this is this is what being
on a hit TV show gets is gorgeous yeah
no she's good I've never actually I've
never really met a celebrity that I
didn't like was just kind of like a
bizarre thing are you impressed with
Courtney and Coco's social media usage
lately they've been killing it oh there
are they making a lot of tic TOCs
yeah yeah that's I'm every time I see
any saliva on tic-tac like a part of me
goes wow like this is it's so exciting
because it's like if I'm entering like
my world what do you make I mean
tick tock especially during this time of
quarantine has like exploded
do you prefer tick tock to a platform
like YouTube are they both necessary
I think tick tock is so interesting guys
it gives every single person or a voice
like even like the most regular person
like will will have something funny to
do and then everybody will see it I just
I really like the algorithm on there
that's how I think so many videos gets
so popular on there that's especially
why if like a new celebrity comes on
their first pack is always always does
so well because it's their first video
on their page and everybody's
interacting with it
so right out to so many people I don't
know I think it's such a necessity and
it's like and it's so easy to use like
the best part about six pack is you can
be creative and you can not be creative
at all do you watch Tic Tac I go into
talking and I'm still on it three hours
later right yeah and I think anybody
that's not on it is because they haven't
given
the shop especially cause like the
algorithm like tailors everything to you
and so like you're literally seeing the
videos you want to see like my knife it
is all like funny videos and then my
sister Taylor's it's literally all cat
video before I let you go jus last
things can we get a mini house tour of
where your quarantine can you sort of
set the scene for us a mini house for
sure where's Natalie hi Natalie you're
such a good sport I can't believe you
sat through all of that this is Taylor
hey Taylor I'm sorry I worked out I'm in
today this is my living room
oh thank you yeah yeah I think it's just
the connections bad so you don't see how
messy it is and then right here
Tesla just sent me this car it's really
cool it's what when you get when you got
I think two referrals so I referred some
people to buy a Tesla you want me they
send me a little baby car this is my
backyard and this is Ilya Ilya say hi
how are you liking away the new Brazil
but yeah we need more outdoor furniture
it's um it's really lacking out there oh
we have a 2008 I know we're trying to
build a pool oh here let me show you so
so this is this right here like we're
trying to build like this infinity pool
here so it'll I go off the edge and then
back yeah a half half court basketball
hoop
so yeah that'll be really cool but that
that's going to take like a year so I
don't want to get any furniture until we
like completely demolish yeah I love it
all right and then do you have a message
to your fans right now either a message
of like hope or staying safe anything
that you want to put out into the
universe I someone tweeted this the
other day I think it's really important
just because you're stuck inside doesn't
mean you have to come out of this
quarantine with like the best body or
like a new
idea or like a new song or a new
screenplay but you don't have to spend
this time like working on yourself and
making something incredible happened
like literally just just hang out and
just relax don't feel the pressure to
make something up this time because
everyone this is in such a weird funk
right now that it's important to just
kind of take it easy and take a
day-by-day
[Music]